[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 13 avril
joe biden propose à vladimir poutine un
sommet dans les prochains mois le
kremlin de son côté affirme que les
présidents russe et américain arrêté
près poursuivre le dialogue pour
garantir la sécurité mondiale
déclarations d'apaisement alors que
l'ukraine est au coeur des échanges
tendus entre les deux pays à dubaï d'un
appel à la russie à faire baisser les
tensions à la frontière ukrainienne
moscou de son côté accusé washington et
l'otan de transformer l'ukraine en
poudrière
la question du dombass objet également
d'une réunion au siège de l'otan
aujourd'hui et demain les vols entre la
france et le brésil suspendu jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
jean castex a finalement tranché cet
après midi s'alignant ainsi avec les
positions du royaume uni et du portugal
en ligne de mire invariants 10 brésilien
encore minoritaires en france moins de
5% des contaminés mais plus contagieux
et plus dangereux qui fait craindre une
quatrième vague
[Musique]
le 1er mars dernier il fallait encore
quelques semaines a4 a6 emmanuel macron
donner des perspectives aux français
menacés par une vie faite de mesures de
confinement ou de couvre feu depuis
plusieurs mois six semaines après force
est de constater qu'il faut encore tenir
jusqu'à quand le calendrier n'est pas
encore connu que peut-on alors attendre
des promesses du chef de l'état nous en
parlement avec l exquis poulain dans son
édito
[Musique]
le crès nos coeurs dont des tensions
géopolitiques une fois encore la russie
met en garde l'otan et washington contre
le risque de transformer l'ukraine en
poudrière
elle leur reproche de renforcer les
capacités de défense de kiev joba aidé à
lui propose un sommet avec les limites
poutine dans un pays tiers les deux
présidents qui se disent prêtes à
fournir le dialogue pour garantir la
sécurité mondiale antoine clermont vous
rejoins en direct de moscou vous êtes
notre correspondant pourquoi
assiste-t-on à une escalade des tensions
à la frontière entre l'ukraine et la
russie
oui bien fait tout dépend de quel côté
on se trouve tout dépend qui l'on écoute
kiev prétend que la hausse des tensions
est due à la concentration de troupes
russes à sa frontière tandis que moscou
dénonce des provocations de la part de
l'armée ukrainienne
mais cette fois au niveau de la ligne de
contact cette ligne de contact qui
sépare les troupes ukrainienne d'à côté
des forces des républiques
autoproclamées de donner ce qu'elle de
lougansk de l'autre la russie admis
avoir organisé des mouvements de troupes
dans cette région mais a souligné que ce
qui se passe sur le territoire russe ne
regarde qu'elle
et que sa seule préoccupation est
d'assurer sa propre sécurité
par contre moscou voit d'un mauvais oeil
l'arrivée de troupes de l'otan dont de
nombreux soldats américains tout au long
de sa frontière européenne de la mer
baltique à la mer noire ont coûté des
forces importantes de l'otan sont
concentrées dans les régions de la mer
noire et de la baltique au total jusqu'à
quarante mille soldats quinze mille
armes et des équipements militaires
comprenant de l'aviation stratégique
sont concentrées près de notre
territoire
en réponse à l'activité militaire de
l'alliance qui menace la russie nous
avons pris des mesures appropriées
on assiste donc à une accumulation de
forces armées d'un côté comme de l'autre
ce qui multiplie les risques d'incidents
et participe donc à cette hausse des
tensions et antoine chauvet d'année
vladimir poutine se sont entretenus au
téléphone
oui et les deux hommes ont campé sur
leurs positions le président américain a
fait savoir que washington continuait de
soutenir l'intégrité territoriale de
l'ukraine et son homologue russe a
rappelé son attachement à la résolution
politique du conflit sur la base des
accords de minsk mais malgré leurs
différends les deux hommes vous l'avez
évoqué pourraient se rencontrer dans les
prochains mois dans un pays tiers
avec pour objectif d'apaiser la
situation et plus globalement de bâtir
je cite une relation stable et
prévisible entre les deux pays mais pour
en revenir plus spécifiquement à
l'ukraine la séquence diplomatique
elle continue avec la réception de
volodymyr zielinski par emmanuel macron
à l'elysée ce vendredi afin de tenter de
trouver des solutions pour enrayer ces
tensions merci antoine gayraud en direct
de moscou et pour aller plus loin dans
l'analyse monseur nous avec pierre
laurin journaliste spécialiste de l'ex
urss
bonsoir pierre laurin merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france joe biden
qui appelle donc la russie à faire
baisser les tensions à la frontière
ukrainienne moscou de son côté qui
accusent washington et l'otan de
transformer d'ukraine en poudrière
deux visions deux positions
inconciliables
rien est inconciliable en dire en
diplomatie
là actuellement on assiste à une hausse
des tensions c'est très clair en
revanche s'il faut bien que ça s'arrête
parce que personne n'a intérêt à lancer
un conflit d'envergure
or ce qui risque de se passer ce n'est
pas du tout que on se trouve soudain
dans le disons la situation de 2014 avec
des escarmouches de part et d'autre de
la frontière qui montent progressivement
en intensité mais ce n'était pas à
proprement parler une guerre là il y a
une implication directe non seulement
des forces d'ukrainiens mais également
des forces de l'otan et on ne sait pas
ce qui peut se passer dans ces
conditions là donc je crois que le but
de
la conversation entre la dîmière poutine
et joba eden c'est de calmer le jeu et
de donner des perspectives
même si ce sont des perspectives à plus
long terme ce n'est pas tout de suite
qu'il y aura une rencontre il faudra la
préparer mais de part et d'autre le
disons le contrat et de temporiser
jusqu'à temps qu'on trouve des solutions
danse avec la russie est appelée à faire
abaisser détention par washington
de l'autre côté la russie parle de
poudrière ukrainienne c'est le cas c'est
le sait le mot exact une poudrière dans
la région je crois que plus il y adeux
force de part et d'autre de la ligne de
front plus il risque d'y avoir des
dérapages c'est donc effectivement une
poudrière maintenant ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que l'accumulation des
forces est essentiellement pour le
moment du côté ukrainien de la ligne de
front
du côté des républiques autoproclamées
de donetsk de lougansk les choses sont à
peu près stables
il n'ya pas effectivement il y à des
mouvements ce qui se rapproche de la
ligne de front
ce qui est logique étant donné que de
l'autre côté c'est ce qui se passe mais
en revanche les forces en russie sont
loin de la ligne de front
ce sont des forces qui sont destinés
selon la partie russe à prévenir
éventuellement tout dérapage de la part
de l'ukraine et de l'otan qui viserait
le territoire russe où la crimée parce
que c'est ça qui est actuellement dans
la ligne de mire c'est que il y à une
accumulation de troupe ukrainienne
du côté de la crimée où nord donc de la
péninsule de crimée mais également des
des vaisseaux des navires de l'otan qui
sont en mer noire et qui semble destinée
à se renforcer
or le protocole enfin les accords de
montreux
exige que les navires qui ne font pas
partie qui n'appartiennent pas aux pays
riverains de la mer noire ne peuvent
rester en mer noire que trois semaines
et on assiste depuis maintenant quelques
mois à une noria permanente de navires
de l'otan qui entrent et qui sortent et
avec une présence armée qui est vraiment
très fort et ça ça inquiète beaucoup les
russes et c'est intéressant ce que vous
nous dites parce qu'en substance les
exercices un des russes ça se trouve
près un jeune libyen près des frontières
du craignait non-réaction donc à des
activités selon les russes menaçante de
l'otan alors que kiev accuse moscou de
masser des troupes dans son voisinage
c'est à dire qu'il se rapproche
dangereusement des frontières c'est une
différence notoire quand même mais à
écouter je crois que le problème là
effectivement il ya une différence
d'interprétation comme je crois que le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov répondait à une question
sur justement la présence des troupes
russes à cet endroit et ils disaient
mais c'est là que nous habitons c'est
notre pays
effectivement c'est là que les russes
habite donc il y ait des forces russes
là où les russes habite ça ne semble pas
choqué la communauté internationale
enfin ça ne devrait pas choquer la
communauté internationale comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui
il faut bien voir que de l'autre côté il
y a également des troupes de l'otan en
particulier des troupes américaines mais
pas seulement qui se trouve elle a plus
de 6000 km2 l'heure de leur territoire
donc je crois que là on est en train de
monter en épingle des choses qui sont
relativement simples
imaginons que pour une raison inconnue
un pays proches de la france disons la
suisse accumule des troupes à la
frontière avec la france
est ce que la france ne regarderai pas
ça avec intérêt et est ce que l ne
déploieraient pas quelques unités pour
veiller au grain pour parler pallier à
toute éventualité
je crois que c'est ce que font tous les
pays donc je ne vois pas pourquoi dans
ce cas là la russie ne ferai pas la même
chose
malgré ce contexte évidemment qu'on
s'est tendu y compris avec un washington
on vient de le dire
on apprend par les services de
renseignement américains dans leur
rapport annuel sur les menaces à l'égard
des états unis que la russie ne veut pas
d'un conflit direct avec les états unis
même si je cite elle va poursuivre ses
efforts de déstabilisation contre
l'ukraine
dans le même temps joe biden et venir
poutine se sont entretenus au téléphone
joe biden qui souhaitent organiser un
sommet avec son homologue russe dans un
pays tiers le kremlin qui de son côté
affirme qu'il est prêt pour suivre que
les deux sont prêts à poursuivre le
dialogue pour garantir la sécurité
mondiale malgré les tensions en coupe à
la communication c'est une bonne chose
ah ben c'est toujours une bonne chose
que les canaux diplomatiques fonctionne
d'ailleurs ils servent à cela la
diplomatie n'est pas destinée à discuter
entre amis
mais voir également avec les adversaires
potentiels
quelles sont les solutions à trouver là
où il y avait des frottements et des
situations conflictuelles
elle c'est très clair donc là on revient
dix on a une situation un peu plus
normale après trois mois de présidence
de joba et d'un aux états unis où
effectivement
baden a essayé de montrer qu'il était le
patron qu'il était le chef que les
choses allaient changer que etc
maintenant ce qui concerne la russie
bien entendu la russie comme tous les
autres pays du monde n'ont pas intérêt à
un conflit quelconque
en ce qui concerne les ingérences
éventuelle bombe à ça chacun est libre
d'interpréter les situations comme il
l'entend mais ce qui est très clair
c'est qu'il n'y a pas tellement
longtemps en 2018
joe biden disait se vanter d'avoir fait
dégager un procureur général ukrainien
alors si ce n'est pas une ingérence bon
voila merci beaucoup pierre laurin
d'avoir été avec on vous acceptez votre
analyse hommes sur le front du coc vide
à présent près de 6000 patients en soins
critiques un chiffre jamais atteint
depuis la mi avril 2020 en france
également des inquiétudes autour de la
propagation des variants et les déboires
du nouveau vaccin johnson and johnson
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite thomas bonnet en direct de
l'assemblée nationale bonsoir thomas
bonnet
le premier ministre a donc annoncé de
nouvelles la mesure à l'assemblée pour
tenter d'empêcher la diffusion du
variant brésilien en france où il aura
fallu attendre plusieurs jours de
tergiversations pour qu'enfin le
gouvernement annonce des restrictions
fortes concernant donc les vols en
provenance du brésil je propose
d'écouter jean castex le premier
ministre c'était cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale
nous constatons que la situation
s'aggrave et nous avons donc décidé de
suspendre jusqu'à nouvel ordre tous les
vols entre le brésil et la france
alors après ces annonces il reste quand
même encore quelques inconnues quid des
autres pays d'amérique latine où le
variant circulent également et puis quid
de la guyane qui on le rappelle possède
une très grande frontière terrestre avec
le brésil pour noter que avant ces
annonces jusqu alors les règles étaient
assez floue en la matière avec des
avions qui continuait d'atterrir
quotidiennement sur le territoire
français en provenance du brésil avec
pour seule contrainte pour les voyageurs
le fait de présenter un test pcr
négative datant de moins de 72 heures et
à déclarer sur l'honneur lors de leur
arrivée en france qu'ils allaient
respecter une période d'isolement de dix
jours et puis du côté du gouvernement il
ya encore très peu de temps jusqu'à ce
week-end on se voulait plutôt rassurant
en appelant ans je cite à l'engagement
et à la responsabilité de chacun écoute
est par exemple le ministre clément
bonne il ya très peu d'arrivées
d'habitude vous avez près de 50000
personnes qui arrivent du brésil on est
à mille par semaine aujourd'hui on a été
très sérieux sur la fermeture des
frontières
un nouveau revirement pour le
gouvernement thomas qui a donc cédé à la
pression d'élus et de scientifiques qui
alerté depuis déjà plusieurs jours sur
la menace de ce variant et génère du
brésil oui ça fait un moment que des
voix s'élèvent pour attirer l'attention
de l'exécutif sur le risque que peut
représenter ce nouveau variant ce
variant que l'on appelle p1 qui seraient
en grande partie responsables de la
flambée épidémique au brésil il ya une
donnée qui inquiète particulièrement
la majorité des brésiliens souffrent du
coc vite 19 en soins intensifs ont
désormais moins de 40 ans à variant qui
serait également plus contagieux et plus
résistants aux vaccins c'est donc une
menace prise très au sérieux par les
scientifiques qui craignent que ce
variant ne devienne majoritaire en
france provoquant alors une nouvelle
augmentation des contaminations alors
pour l'heure selon des estimations ce
variant représenterait moins de 5% des
contaminations en france et dans le même
temps thomas on appris aujourd'hui que
le déploiement du vexin johnson and
johnson était retardé
oui cela fait suite à la décision
américaine de suspendre l'utilisation de
ce vaccin qui serait à l'origine de la
formation de caillots sanguins au moins
six cas ont été rapportés ces derniers
jours aux états unis avec une personne
notamment qui est décédé lors les
autorités sanitaires ont décidé de faire
une pause dans les injections du vaccin
johnson & johnson
conséquence le déploiement en europe est
lui aussi repoussé serait ce qui risque
d'avoir un impact très concret pour le
calendrier fixé par le gouvernement il
faut rappeler que la france a reçu hier
deux cent mille doses de ce vaccin
johnson & johnson vrai merci thomas
bonne et on direct de l'assemblée
nationale
alors le gouvernement at il agi assez
vite face au danger du varions brésilien
quid de la stratégie sanitaire française
doit-on craindre une quatrième vague
plus meurtrière place à notre décryptage
avec nos invités et pour en parler
philippe froguel généticien chu de lille
et à l'impérial college de londres
bonsoir philippe rogué merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés laurent alexandre
essayiste et chirurgiens bonsoir à vous
aussi laurent alexandre enfin daniel
abimi médecin du consulat de france à
sao paulo pour nous parler un petit peu
de ce variant qui nous fait si peur le
variant brésilien bonsoir daniel abîme
merci à tous les trois d'avoir accepté
notre invitation donc s'est terminée en
les liaisons paris rio dé janeiro face
au tollé politique le premier ministre
on l'a vu a pris des mesures la
suspension de tous les vols avec le le
brésil 1 il faut le préciser
ce variant ses 4 5% des contaminations
ce qu'il fallait prendre cette décision
pour éviter une propagation massive en
tant que scientifique il ya une forme de
soulagement finit pas au problème
c'est ce qu'on demandait depuis
plusieurs semaines qu'il ya un contrôle
aux frontières contrôles aux frontières
seraient pas dire obligatoirement
d'arrêter les vols qui viennent de un
endroit où dans un autre c'est que tous
les vols de l'étranger qui est des
français de dents ou des étrangers
soient soumis aux mêmes règles comme en
angleterre
comme en israël et dans d'autres pays
c'est à dire qu'on a des vrais contrôles
qu'on les met réellement en quarantaine
et si on trouve au bout de quelques
jours une pcr positif qu'on fasse le
séquençage de la souche virale pour
savoir ce que c'est là on a fait le
brésil mais en a aussi en guyane
française comme il a été dit il y en a
aussi au canada en colombie britannique
et donc il faut faire très attention
aussi au chili et au pérou est donc en
fait toute l'amérique du sud est
contaminé par cette souche est pas une
surprise et tous les vols doivent être
extrêmement surveillé ça me paraît tout
à fait logique
c'est ce qu'il faut faire et vous dis
moi j'ai demandé il ya trois semaines
j'ai proposé ça guam en est à trois
semaines je suis content que oui trois
semaines on commence à faire un petit
quelque chose
les trois semaines pour bien comprendre
justement ce que vous nous dites
regarder à 37 pays et les 37 pays qui
sont touchés
sur cette carte par ce variant brésilien
comme vous nous l'expliqué philippe
froguel
une grosse partie de l'amérique du sud
vous laurent alexandre vous trouviez un
peu réaliste justement ce matin je vous
écoute et la suspension des vols vous
préconisiez davantage de restrictions
aux aéroports des mesures plus sévères
quand on voit effectivement cette carte
avec plein de pays on se doute que tous
les vols de ces pays vont pas être
suspendu qu'est ce que vous nous dites
ce soir déjà le variant brésilien est
présent en europe et pas uniquement ou
au portugal
il est extrêmement compliqué
d'interrompre les vols entre la guyane
française
et puis et puis la métropole vous savez
d'ailleurs que la plus grande frontière
terrestre française c'est avec le brésil
830 km de frontière donc de toute façon
il va y avoir des variants brésilien il
ya plusieurs sous types qui vont qui
vont apparaître
donc ce qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est d'augmenter le testing et le
traçage surtout s'ils étaient s'il était
prouvé dans les semaines qui viennent ce
qui n'est pas encore totalement certain
que les nouveaux variants suis
d'amérique
un sont résistants aux principaux
vaccins en cours donc on voit bien que
la vaccination ne suffira pas même si
elles étaient efficaces et même et
d'at&t harry plus soutenue elle ne
suffira pas il va falloir y associer des
quarantaines ciblée sur les gens qui ont
été testés positifs ça suppose d'une
organisation importante parce que on
voit bien depuis un an il ya une chose
que la france n'a jamais su faire c'est
le traçage des gens tester et la mise en
quarantaine
donc aujourd'hui s'il fallait limiter le
développement des des variants sud
américain ce serait assez compliqué
parce que depuis un an
l'administration française a toujours
échoué à faire un tracinda des patients
couchés et ça n'est pas simple parce
qu'on sait bien que le taux élevé de
gens asymptomatiques rend
l'identification des porteurs d
compliqué par ailleurs et c'est le
cheval de bataille de de mon confrère
froga à juste titre il va falloir
augmenter le séquençage arn des virus
il va falloir analyser davantage le pool
de virus présent en france et également
en guyane et ça suppose d'arrêter de
prendre du retard sur le sur le
séquençage arn
ça fait des mois et des mois que les
rebelles demandent au gouvernement
d'accélérer leçon que séquençage des
virus et c'est une nécessité aujourd'hui
il va falloir tracé de façon plus
étroite qu'on le fait encore et on peut
considérer dans les mois qui viennent
les variants sud américains doivent être
identifiés et que les patients suspects
d'avoir d'être infectés par des virus
des différents virus sud américains
doivent avoir un séquençage arn de la
souche virale dont il souffre sinon on
va avoir un échappement au vaccin et on
va avoir de nouvelles vagues à partir de
l'été en attendant le moment éventuels
ou les fabricants de vaccins arn
messagers serait capable
fournir une troisième injection pour les
nouveaux variants effectivement pas très
rassurant d'autant qu'au brésil ce
variant amazonien semble hors de
contrôle 4000 morts par jour plus de
350000 depuis le début de la pandémie et
ce qui inquiète encore davantage c'est
que plus de 50 2,2 pour cent des
hospitalisés au moins de 40 ans c'est
quand même une nouveauté pas très
rassurante daniela be comment expliquer
cette situation au brésil c'est la faute
uniquement à ce type de variants où il
ya d'autres explications
c'est le rail
évidemment le 29 on sait certainement
ses plus beaux il ya une fois c'est ici
le camerounais dans le jeune ils ont
tellement ce qui l'animé c'est normal on
ne peut pas signer plus létale ou pense
que même moi vraiment non et c'est quand
ces corps génétique on en perd dans la
ville de sao paulo il ya deux semaines
nous donnaient les numéros un peu on
avait deux tiers des patients
elle est écoutée par la finma n'a donc
malheureusement c'est une souche qui
sévit céline boulud rapidement dans le
foyer de l'épidémie
je pense que maintenant faut
probablement on arrive à 75 80 % de
souche manaus pour les nouveaux cas donc
c'est vraiment inquiétant il faut
vraiment qu'on fasse attention les
mesures de loeb dani reese nul non
j'arrête très bien parce que vu la
pauvreté du pays les gens ont besoin de
sortir et de travailler ou alors de
rester à la maison
les subventions de l'état son petit les
gens finissent pas sentir s'agglomérer
dans une amphore public philips a
redonné mois dernier la ville parce
qu'on peut on a compris heureusement les
données essentielle de votre message
mais c'est vrai que la liaison était un
petit peu compliqué philippe froguel
et faire les gros yeux en entendant
daniela habib nous parler de ce type de
souche de variants oui je sais c'est
tout à fait affolant parce que il ya la
souche bien qu'on la retrouvait en
france nous on a à peu près deux
personnes chaque semaine qu'on retrouve
à lille porteuse de paix 1
en france on fait surtout de la pcr de
tryba g on sait pas en réalité à paris à
la ph pire ne s'est pas fait la
différence entre le sud africain et le
brésilien ce qui est quand même
particulièrement inquiétant j'ai mon
cousin et qui portait un emploi qui est
à l'ap-hp il me racontait sa encore
aujourd'hui c'est donc il ne sait pas si
les gens sont là on la souche il
africaine ou là où la brésilienne et
puis la brésilienne va encore bouger et
on risque d'avoir encore une forme
encore plus encore plus grave c'est pour
ça que il faut un combiné tout un tas de
choses y compris le traçage rétrospectif
c'est à dire que ces gens ils sont venus
quelques ports et essayer de voir ce
qu'on n'a jamais réussit bien à faire en
france hélas mais s'il essayait de le
faire et puis il faut mobiliser la
population pour ça que les autotests ça
peut être aussi utile si on l'est
vraiment on les aide
on l'a on me permet d'aller partout sur
une bande la population mon cousin me
disais tout à l'heure
donc on a quelqu'un qui a varié en
probablement brésilien et sa famille est
au travail parce que personne ne leur a
dit de ne rien faire et donc ça risque
vraiment se dissémine était très inquiet
l'inspection log à paris effectivement
en mesure votre inquiétude est juste
titre je vous propose de regarder ce
tweet un du professeur rémy salomon
président de la commission médicale
d'établissement de l'ap-hp
justement elle le variant en p1 est
nettement plus contagieux que le b 117
quelques cas déjà présent en europe
si on ne fait rien pour ralentir son
arrivée nous aurons une belle 4ème vague
avant d'avoir suffisamment vacciner on
se décide à faire quelque chose mais le
nerf de la guerre justement les vaccins
laurent
alexandre on aura passé suffisamment
vacciner selon vous pour l'éviter cette
quatrième vague d'autant que maintenant
on augmenta le délai des deux doses a en
tout cas pour files heures et modern a
alors on a deux problèmes
est ce que quelqu'un qu'elle sera la
sensibilité des différents variant
sud-américain autour du p1 au vaccin
pour l'instant on n'a pas encore de
certitudes et spéciale c'est la première
inquiétude puis la deuxième inquiétude
c'est qu'elle sera lorsque la vague de
p1 va se développer
quel sera le taux d'immunité vaccinale
et non vaccinale en europe continentale
on sait qu'à l'heure actuelle le retard
est très important dans la vaccination
dans l'union européenne puisque la
france sera dans deux mois
là au nombre de vaccinés des états unis
d'aujourd'hui
la france sera dans trois mois au niveau
de vaccination de l'angleterre au moment
où nous parlons et la france sera dans
six mois
au niveau de vaccination ou et israël
aujourd'hui donc la france selon l'écart
entre deux et six mois de retard par
rapport aux pays qui en vacciner
rapidement donc il est illusoire de
penser que dans les semaines qui
viennent on va avoir une immunité
collective dans des pays comme
l'allemagne la france ou la belgique
à supposer même que les variants
sud-américain soit correctement sensible
à l'astra syndicats et aux deux vaccins
arn messagers donc de toutes façons la
vague du p1
sauf miracle qu'on va se la prendre en
pleine tronche dans les semaines qui
viennent si on ne développe pas encore
le testing le tracking la surveillance
et la mise en quarantaine des gens qui
sont porteurs parce que la vaccination a
un petit peu accéléré en mai mais pas
beaucoup
et puis il est probable qu'on va prendre
des retards encore sur les vaccins
produits à partir d' adénovirus 1 on le
voit dès à présent avec le le stockage
et la non distribution des 200 milles
vaccin johnson qui ont été reçus hier
pour pour la france et qui devait
arriver progressivement dans dans les
semaines qui viennent
donc on va continuer à vacciner
lentement en tout cas plus lentement que
les pays qui sont très avancés dans
leurs plans matinale l'ont fait donc la
protection par le vaccin va être limité
donc il est probable que l'on va
connaître une période difficile jusqu'à
mi juin
il n'est pas du tout certain que la
promesse ou la quasi promesse du
président de la république de réouvrir
les lieux de culture et les terrasses de
restaurants et de bars mi mai soit tenu
compte tenu de cette évolution
épidémiologique délétère et de la
poursuite du routard vaccinale à daniel
hamiche quand vous entendez le docteur
laurent alexandre du brésil vous avez
l'impression que les européens mesure
correctement le le danger de ce variant
amazonien et qu'on fait ce qu'il faut
ici en france écoutez moi je pense qu'il
a tout à fait raison il ya deux
problèmes d'abord c'est le retard
vaccinale parce qu'on vaccine groupe e
et surtout accélère ça parce que c'est
là où couper les bides et line pour qu
on n'a pas vu daniel habib ou pardon
philippe froguel
laurent alexandre nous parler un tout à
l'heure de cet autre mauvaise nouvelle
après des déboires d'astrazeneca
johnson and johnson impose dans la
livraison après amor quand même par
thrombose aux états unis l'afrique du
sud qui suspend officiellement ce soir
la vaccination nous forcément il y aura
une pause
on imagine que ça va pas arranger nos
affaires tout ça on sait exactement ce
qu'il va se passer
laurent alexandre l'a dit très
clairement on a trois mois de retard sur
sur les britanniques
ce matin ma fille m'a envoyé une photo
de londres elle prenait un café sur une
terrasse
et puis à la néo pop ce soir avec des
amis à l'extérieur on voit on mesure la
très grosse différence entre à l'europe
occidental et l'angleterre où israël et
tout ça est tragique parce que si
effectivement le variant p1 ou le
variant du variant est associé à des
formes très grave à 40 ans on sait très
bien que les gens de 40 ans ne seront
pas vacciner massivement avoir mois de
juillet août voire septembre président
de république nous a promis pour la fin
de l'été
pour moi c'est le 21 septembre donc je
crains qu'on va avoir les hôpitaux plein
temps en temps pendant pendant l'été
l'autre chose moi qui m'a frappé c'est
l'annnonce de l'europe qui on allait
comme monde et 1,5 milliard de nouveaux
vaccins
on sait pas lesquels on sait pas où ils
sont faits ça me rappelle exactement ce
qui s'est passé pendant l'été dernier où
on allait au supermarché et en
commandait le vaccin moins cher alors
qu'on aurait dû en réalité avoir les
vaccins irène lui personne voulait à
l'époque de vaccins a dit à irin ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il va falloir
préparer le coup d'après les anglais le
prépare et pas par une autre vaccination
avec des vaccins à plus large spectre à
la rentrée l'iranien pareil j'ai un peu
l'impression qu'en europe on
comme toujours on subit l'événement sans
vraiment sûr ni scientifiquement ni
théologiquement ni industriellement le
le préparer ça me ça m'attriste
énormément alors alexandre on est un
petit peu plombé là on se rend compte
sur ce plateau mais est ce que vous vous
dites c est assez édifiant sur gagnon
dit il faut avoir un train d'avancé
vous anticipez coup d'après sauf que
nous on a deux trains de retard à chaque
fois comment n'at-on pas pris enfin la
mesure
d'où vient cette cette phase est
incompétent cette irresponsabilité je ne
sais pas comment l'appeler vous savez
c'est très simple il faut prendre
l'interview du président de la
république à la bpia la banque publique
d'investissement le 12 octobre dernier
le président emmanuel macron expliqué
devant les banquiers et devant les
investisseurs ceux qui prétendent qu'il
pourrait y avoir un vaccin contre le coc
vide
au printemps 2000 21 trompent les
français il n'y aura pas de vaccins au
printemps prochain
c'était le 12 octobre le président de la
république en octobre pendant que israël
l'angleterre et les états unis lançait
un programme massif de vaccination
le président de la république était
persuadé qu'il n'y aurait pas de vaccin
avant la fin 2021 voir me 2022 et
beaucoup de dirigeants européens ont
comme macron penser qu'il n'y aurait pas
de vaccin donc ils n'ont pas préparé un
plan rapide de vaccination macron comme
madame merkel s'est préparé pour
vacciner à partir de l'été 2021 parce
qu'ils ne croyaient pas à l'arrivée du
vaccin il n'avait pas vu que les vaccins
arn messagers pouvait être produits plus
rapidement donc le retard européen il
est d'abord une faille d'analystes
technologique
les conseillers du président mais c'est
le cas aussi à bruxelles autour de la
commission européenne n'ont pas cru au
développement rapide des vaccins contre
le coc vide et donc l'europe ne s'est
pas préparé à vacciner vite elle ne
s'est pas préparé à commander les
vaccins
on retrouve d'ailleurs ce même
aveuglement dans ce tweet d'anthologie
du ministre des affaires étrangères
clément boon qui le 23 décembre dernier
tweet victoire
l'europe va payer les vaccins deux fois
moins cher que les autres pays la france
et l'union européenne se félicitait en
décembre d'avoir renié quelques dollars
sur les vaccins
l'europe n'avait pas compris que l'enjeu
n'était pas de payer 2 3 ou 4 $ de moins
les vaccins c'était de vacciner vite
quitte à payer les vaccins plus cher ce
qu'a fait israël ce qu'a fait
l'angleterre est ce qu a fait l aux
états unis donc cet aveuglement de
l'europe il a été très très important et
on en paie aujourd'hui les pots cassés
il faut que l'europe se réveille bien
sûr et puis il va falloir que l'europe
comme israël et l'angleterre et les
etats-unis réfléchissent au
développement de nouveaux vaccins contre
les nouveaux variants dans l'hypothèse
où il était avéré que les nouveaux
variants sont résistants aux vaccins
actuels israël est avec modern en train
de réfléchir à une troisième injection
de vaccin et rennes contre les nouveaux
variants l'angleterre comme le disait
philippe froguel il réfléchit aussi il
faut que l'europe anticipent cette fois
ci le coup d'après et cessent d'avoir
six mois de retard sur les autres pays
développés
philippe froguel le problème comme nous
l'a dit à laurent lexandre c'était
peut-être ne pas voir les mesures mais
c'est pas aussi d'avoir fait surtout les
mauvais pari parce qu emmanuel macron
tenait son accent français qui n'a
jamais vu le jour
moi j'ai des copains qui ont fait partie
de la commission qui ont négocié en fin
du groupe qui a négocié avec l'europe
il me disait que hélas les conseillers
scientifiques ce vous voyez à la télé et
qui ont des responsabilités encore
aujourd'hui était à fond pour bloquer ou
en tout cas ne pas développer les
vaccins et rennes et on a tous entendu
d'un mois de septembre mois d'octobre un
certain nombre de collègues qui ont dit
ah ben c'est très dangereux ça sera pas
efficace
donc c'est bon t'as un gouvernement est
mal conseillé par ces scientifiques
eh bien c'est ce qui se passe alors
peut-être qu'on peut dire que monsieur
mac romain merkel ont pas choisi les
bons scientifiques qui falaise pas c'est
possible mais l'europe est frileuse
devant le progrès est frileuse devant la
technologie moderne et le principe de
précaution c'est ça qui nous a tués on a
dit voilà qu'est ce que ça va être
dangereux
ah bah oui ben c'était utile ça sauve
les vies et les vieux vaccin ceux qui
sont adénovirus et dubaï ont ils ont des
problèmes à billets et voilà ce qui veut
dire que de temps en temps il faut
au progrès et pas simplement pensé ces
vieilles lunes qui pensent que on fait
des choses comme on le faisait il ya 30
ans et là si on a beaucoup de jeunes ces
vieilles lunes
ils sont chez sa fille à pasteur ou dans
certains atteignaient la bible le mot de
la fin pour vous au brésil quid de la de
la vaccination même si on le sait la
situation est catastrophique
il ya eu d'autres choix quand même
d'autres arbitrages liban avec des
vaccins encore en arabe on va de
s'introduire avec astrazeneca le vaccin
d'or seront malheureusement comme on ne
sait pas si ça va obliger ces nouvelles
barioz s'est heureusement on n'a pas
encore assez de recul tenir par rapport
à nantes on sait pas très bien comment
ça va se passer
ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui audrey nul
et que la motivation est encore apparue
une langue quand on voit ça c'est
vraiment très préoccupant parce que ça
permet vraiment de circuler m j'espère
peut on aura pu vacciner beaucoup plus
d'endroits moi mais si vous avez
d'autres ans de retard on en a trois ans
de retard et ça c'est le gros problème
par rapport à l'animation de ces
nouvelles variantes et surtout en plus
le nombre de morts et les cats ont que
ça produit donc là ils sont vraiment
pour l'instant nouveau malheureusement
perdu un petit peu daniel abîmées on
accomplit en substance le message merci
infiniment tous les trois philippe
froguel laurent alexandre et daniela be
même si vous nous avez un petit peu
plombé le moral ce soir merci en tout
cas de vous être exprimé en direct sur
rt france et face à la crise sanitaire
emmanuel macron à tenter de fixer des
objectifs parfois rattrapés par les
mauvais chiffres alors que peut-on
attendre de ces fameuses promesses du
chef de l'état pour en parler nous
sommes avec alexis poulain c'est notre
rubrique l'édito
un bon soir alexis poulain merci d'être
avec nous j'espère vous n'êtes pas trop
déprimé après l'analyse de nos chers
scientifiques qui nous on voit là un
petit peu mis un coup de froid sur ce
plateau
j'ai tout seul mais bon voilà alors on
se demande chers alexis qui attendent
les promesses du président macro il
avait dit encore quatre à six semaines
d'efforts on tiens c'était il ya six
semaines aujourd'hui où en sommes-nous
sur le front de la crise oui alors c'est
vrai pas autant essayer d'en rire
effectivement parce que sinon c'est la
déprime qui nous guette d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron ira demain dans un
service de pédopsychiatrie pour voir les
enfants qui souffrent beaucoup
des mesures de confinement qui ont été
imposées alors c'est vrai il ya six
semaines il nous disait dans quatre à
six semaines vous allez voir on va
assouplir ces mesures bon on est
maintenant il ya six semaines dans le
futur l'épidémiologiste en chef et que
nous sommes toujours sous des mesures de
confinement de couvre-feu avec des
mesures ubuesques comme le port du
masque sur la plage alors que la
communiquer la part dans la
contamination extérieure est très faible
avec l'interdiction de consommer de
l'alcool sur la voie publique ou même de
mettre de la musique amplifiée sur la
voie publique
allez savoir des fois que le virus aime
danser tout ça fait qu'on continue avec
l'absurde east hants autoritaire ça ça
n'a pas changé
ce qui a changé c'est peut-être les
promesses sur la vaccination là il ya eu
plusieurs quoi quand on se rappelle
astrazeneca évidemment avec ses
thrombose veineuse quatre enquêtes sont
en cours
puisqu'il ya eu quatre décès suspects de
personnes à ces jeunes qui avaient reçu
une première dose d'astrazeneca
depuis les français rechignent un peu à
se faire vacciner avec astrazeneca alors
l'objectif est de vacciner 10 millions
mi avril apparemment il est atteint 20
millions mi mai et 30 millions de
français à la mi juin
mais pour ça il va falloir recevoir des
doses et les doses il s'agit bien de
johnson & johnson
malheureusement on apprend aujourd'hui
que le vaccin
et lui aussi provoque quelques soucis et
donc a été mis en cause par l'autorité
de santé américaine et que l'entreprise
johnson & johnson va donc décaler ses
livraisons à l'europe donc encore une
fois ça paraît compliqué de tenir les
dates de vaccination
et puis il ya une promesse qui n'en est
pas une
mais finalement un chiffre fatidique
tragique
les cent mille morts qui risque
d'arriver dans les jours qui viennent et
ça emmanuel macron aimerait tout faire
pour ne pas avoir à le supporter à
l'assumer
ça va être l'objet bien sûr de une
séquence de communication de plus on en
a vu une de séquences de communication
qui a bien fait rire en même temps que
pleurer un c'est un peu là la base de
cette gestion de crise c'est les vols
depuis le brésil
alors dimanche les vols depuis le brésil
selon le ministre des transports a été
contrôlé il y avait très peu de gens qui
arrivaient et on ne pouvait pas de toute
façon arrêter ces vols à cause du droit
international
tout le monde disait mais quand même les
variants brésiliens ont l'air assez
agressif
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas faire des
quarantaines comme dans d'autres pays ou
bien supprimer tout simplement les vols
pendant un temps et non impossible nous
disent et on est bien aujourd'hui jean
castex devant les députés a dit que
c'est bon on va pouvoir suspendre fi du
droit international après tout quand on
veut on peut
c'est ça gérer une crise de manière
politique c'est ce que n'ont pas fait
les membres du gouvernement depuis le
début de cette crise armée en même temps
des efforts ont quand même été fait sur
les promesses de réindustralisation
notamment avec la production de dos sur
le sol national
alors production de doses l'encore ml
macron à jouer sur les mots sur ses
comptes officiels sur les réseaux
sociaux il parlait de produire produire
produire avec des images de ces petites
bouteilles sur les lignes de production
il ne s'agit pas de produire les vaccins
mais d'embouteiller les vaccins dont
qu'il aurait dû mettre en bouteille est
embouteillée embouteillée ouf la connaît
flacco nef la connaît puisque les
les produits actifs ne sont pas produits
sur le territoire elles sont simplement
en bouteille pour qu'on puisse avoir les
doses donc il s'agit simplement là dans
une petite pirouette pour expliquer que
finalement ça y est on va produire alors
on pourrait dire que tout va bien sanofi
par exemple va ouvrir une nouvelle usine
tant mieux mais c'est à singapour encore
raté ça ne sera pas en france donc la
réindustrialisation sur le monde du
médical et et de la pharma ça ne vient
pas encore les promesses de lui aussi
parlons-en rappelez-vous au coeur de la
crise en 2020 on était carrément à
promettre 14 midi d'animations
supplémentaires puis on est passé à 12
min puis dix mille lits et les soignants
peine à voir venir ces nouveaux lits de
réanimation
alors on bricole un avec des réfectoires
d'hôpitaux qui sont transformés en salle
de réanimation
on apprend aussi qu'en octobre une neuf
nouvelles revalorisations salariales
aura lieu pour les soignants mais quand
même là encore on a l'impression que
tout ça est gérée à vue avec aucune
vision stratégique que fait françois
bayrou haut commissariat au plan on a
l'impression que monsieur bayrou et plus
préoccupés par la tenue des élections
régionales est de savoir s'il aurait pu
les décalés pour éviter une défaite
plutôt que par planifier la production
justement les masques qui devait être
produit en france ce n'est pas le cas
des médicaments mais autres et puis voir
comment sauver l'hôpital ou ce qu'il en
reste parce que aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que et bien oui le système de
santé français souffre des mesures
d'austérité qui ont été prises pendant
des années et dans ces conditions alexis
peut-on encore croire aux promesses de
réouverture un même partielle mi mai
pour les restaurants bars et lieux
culturels
alors vous savez l'adage en politique
les promesses n'engagent que ceux qui
veulent bien y croire alors libre à
chacun de croire ou non aux promesses
des malaises macron il se dessine quand
même un mode de gouvernement un basé sur
l'esbroufé la communication bat dernier
reste bof en date jeudi le chef de
l'état va présider un conseil sur
justement le calendrier de réouverture
alors on se demande est ce bien le
moment n'est ce pas un peu prématuré
compte tenu de toutes ces nouvelles
ble ment non il s'agit là de dire que
oui il est sur le terrain qu'il se bat
corps à corps avec ce virus avec aucun
superpouvoir malheureusement il est peut
aider c'est vrai et macron par
jean-michel bancaire qui vient d'être
qu'à contacter roselyne bachelot qui
sauvent et duco vide a pu réintégrer le
ministère de la culture mais quand même
ça fait un gouvernement bien mal en
point
et ça continue avec ses couacs de
vaccination que j'évoquais avec aussi
comment croire ce calendrier de
réouverture quand l'exécutif a tout fait
pour essayer de décaler les régionales
après l'été en septembre les commerçants
eux reste calme et attendre de savoir à
quelle sauce ils vont être réouvert pour
fermer pendant ce temps là on voit des
images d'angleterre ou d'ailleurs où
vous les gens se retrouvent autour de
verre autour de moments conviviaux
alors que nous bien nous sommes toujours
à 19 heures enfermé et nous avons la
capacité de faire plus de 10 kilomètres
au delà de chez nous tandis que les
avions pouvaient venir du brésil jusqu'à
aujourd'hui alors ça reste quand même
compliqué emmanuel macron nous a demandé
à certains notamment aux artistes de
chevaucher le tigre rappelez-vous pour
l'été apprenants on a l'impression que
c'est lui qui est tombé du tigre qui est
par terre et qui a bien du mal à part à
faire diversion pour lancer finalement
cette campagne pour sa réélection qui va
être empêtrés dans le vide
et d'ailleurs la prochaine diversion je
me demande quand est-ce qu'elle va
arriver
vous savez c'est cette vidéo qu'il avait
promise de youtuber mcfly et carlito
pour répondre à des questions un peu
drôle c'est pas le moment non plus je
crois que cette vidéo est remisée dans
les cartons mais merci alexis paulin et
à propos des régionales auxquelles vous
faisiez allusion émana sont mes
nationale soutenue massivement tout à
l'heure le maintien enjoint de ces
régionales et départementales merci à
vous
et retour sur le vieux continent en
proie donc à cette crise sanitaire le
coc vide a fait plus d'un million de
morts en europe le cap symbolique est
manque était franchie hier l'épidémie
reste en pleine expansion s'inquiète le
ms qui évoque un stade critique certains
pays font face plus facilement que
d'autres ainsi en angleterre après avoir
atteint des records le pays le plus
touché d'europe affiche aujourd'hui
moins de 50 décès par jour
conséquence il a entamé hier son
déconfinement bar terrasse et commerces
ont rouvert une situation favorisée par
la campagne de vaccination menée tambour
battant mais pas seulement c'est ce
qu'explique le premier ministre
britannique
il prie aime le pôle it you and start
il est très important que tout le monde
comprenne que la réduction du nombre
d'hospitalisations et de décès et
d'infection n'est pas dû à la campagne
de programmer vaccination
les gens ne réalisent pas je pense que
c'est le confinement qui a été d'une
importance extrême pour permettre ces
progrès face à la pandémie avec les
chiffres que nous observons bien seul et
donc oui évidemment la campagne de
vaccination nous a aidés mais
l'essentiel des progrès pour maîtriser
la maladie ont été réalisés grâce au
confinement donc au fur et à mesure que
nous déconfit non la conséquence surratt
inévitable que nous aurons plus
d'infections et malheureusement nous
aurons plus de trente alisation et de 17
ans tour à la vie normale que les
restaurateurs italiens appellent de
leurs voeux ils manifestent à nouveau ce
mardi pour dénoncer les restrictions
sanitaires et exige la réouverture de
leur établissement pour sortir le pays
de la crise
hier leur mobilisation a tourné à
l'affrontement avec les forces de
l'ordre syriennes bouée avec maya
soubelet deuxième journée de
manifestations sous tension à rome ce
mardi de nombreux restaurateurs et
entrepreneurs se sont à nouveau
rassemblés dans la capitale italienne
durement affectée par les conséquences
de la crise
ils réclament la réouverture des
restaurants ou encore des salles de
sport initiée par le mouvement you apron
ce rassemblement non autorisé à un
objectif clair obtenir une réouverture
d'ici le 20 avril prochain
nous espérons un peu de compréhension de
la part du gouvernement
nous espérons être entendus par les
institutions cela fait en effet si ces
mêmes choses restaurateurs nous avons
anticipé tous ces problèmes
et puis un aussi petit possible que ceux
qui dirigent le pays n'en soient pas
capables de lost à l'état et une dette
envers moi aucune elle ne vient je ne
sais pas comment joindre les deux bouts
nous sommes sur place parce que nous
avons le droit de manifester et de faire
grève et trouver autant de camions de
police parce que je dois faire grève
c'est un état autoritaire
peut-être que c'est bien pour bruxelles
mais pas pour nous nous sommes des
travailleurs nous ne sommes pas des
criminels
les restrictions seront maintenues au
moins jusqu'à la fin du mois d'avril
selon mario draghi
le premier ministre italien conditionne
la réouverture des restaurants à une
baisse des nouveaux cas de kovy 19 mai
table aussi sur son programme vaccinal
jeudi dernier le chef du gouvernement a
rappelé à l'ordre la population en
insistant auprès des personnes de plus
de 60 ans pour qu'elles se fassent
vacciner une stratégie par groupe d'âge
qui fait débat au sein de la sphère
politique italienne
la campanie a été l'une des régions les
plus rigoureuses d'italie mais la
rigueur est une chose la stupidité en
est une autre
je viens de m'entretenir avec le
commissaire philippe où l'eau à qui j'ai
dit qu'une fois que les plus de 80 ans
et les personnes fragiles auront été
traitées nous n'avons pas l'intention de
procéder par groupes d'âge nous
consacrerons la structure publique à la
prise en charge des personnes fragiles
et âgés mais nous travaillerons
également sur les secteurs économiques
car si nous décidons d'avancer
uniquement par groupes d'âge
lorsque nous aurons terminé les groupes
d'âge l'économie italienne sera morte
alors que l'économie italienne semble à
bout de souffle des restaurateurs vont
être reçus par le gouvernement pour
tenter de sortir de l'impasse
outre-rhin présent le gouvernement
allemand approuve un durcissement des
lois sur la protection contre les
infections le projet été approuvé en
conseil des ministres un durcissement
qui va permettre d'imposer une
harmonisation des restrictions dans tout
le pays couvre feu nocturne fermeture
des magasins la chancelière angela
merkel impose sa ligne stricte pour
combattre l'épidémie des nouvelles
règles qui seront mises en place si le
taux d'incidence est supérieur à 100
pendant trois jours tout en oeuvre les
mesures de freinage d'urgence à
l'échelle nationale si le taux
d'incidence est supérieur à 100 et que
la réglementation nationale doit
s'appliquer à l'avenir les mesures de
freinage d'urgence ne seront plus une
question d'interprétation car elles
s'appliqueront automatiquement match ça
me fait du truc belle brême pour que les
choses s'améliorent pour que nous
brisons la troisième vague
les consultations entre le gouvernement
fédéral et les régions ne suffisent plus
notre réponse à la pandémie doit devenir
plus vigoureuse et plus cohérente et
cette semaine des pays vont lever leurs
mesures de restriction mais de façon
très prudente et progressive le portugal
ou encore la grèce tour d'horizon en
images
[Musique]
mu
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la suspension des vols
entre la france et le brésil en raison
de la propagation du variant côté vexe
un nouveau revers le johnson & johnson
marque une pause annoncée aujourd'hui
par les autorités sanitaires américaines
l'apparition oppose draguera grave
pardon caillot sanguin son déploiement
en europe
retardée
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance vous avez
choisi le jour à bagdad alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour étudier dernière
fois l'emprunt c'était en 2011 le monde
manque pas un petit peu non ah oui c'est
tous les fromages trouver ceux ci sont
toutes les les croissants la pâtisserie
traits de caractère des russes qui te
plaît l'amitié les gens les gens très
stylé fallu les français ne savent pas
je ne pensais jamais de ma vie faire la
plonge et autonomie vous pouvez me
souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi au
site
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'ya
pas intervenir on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la sphère art chagos comment ce family
office at il réussi à provoquer un
nouveau vent de panique sur les marchés
mais aussi des pertes massives pour
plusieurs l établissement bancaire
utilisé l'effet de levier pour gagner de
l'argent en bourse ça se fait tous les
jours
en fait c'est toute cette incitation à
toujours pouvoir gagner plus avec
l'argent gratuit de la fed qui a
finalement poussé bon nombre de banques
à suivre mais sûrement c'est quelque
chose qui nous a emmenés dans une
catastrophe en 2007 et en 2008
tous les tous les crédits ficelé goldman
sachs et morgan stanley était évidemment
pas au courant les uns des autres que
arte jégo savez autant d'engagements à
droite à gauche et c'est ton principe de
l'opacité de la chose je peux l'annoncer
dès maintenant vous aurez des archers
gosses en x 10
[Musique]
l'agité pour tous ce que ça apporte aux
enfants c'est une confiance confiance en
soi ils ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des groupes hostiles
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs des écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et à écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
la famille on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison basse année
difficile
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est 21h heure française merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième heure
d'immersion tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 13
avril les vols entre la france et le
brésil suspendu jusqu'à nouvel ordre
si l'hexagone avait renforcé ses
contrôles à l'aéroport face à la
propagation du variant ni brésilien jean
castex a finalement tranché cet après
midi côté vaccins nouveau revers le
johnson and johnson marque une pause
annoncée aujourd'hui par les autorités
sanitaires américaines en cause
l'apparition rare de graff caillots
sanguins son déploiement en europe et
retardé aux états unis mais napoli sous
tension après une deuxième nuit
consécutive de manifestations couvre-feu
a été décrété dans cette ville du nord
des états unis
un millier de soldats de la garde
nationale sont mobilisés et la mort
dimanche d'un jeune homme noir avait tué
par la police lors d'un contrôle routier
suscite l'indignation en plein procès
sur le meurtre de torture floyd l'appel
d'une cinquantaine de ng pour un
changement de stratégie au sel cette
région et ses habitants subissent les
affrontements entre groupes terroristes
via lycée forces de sécurité depuis de
nombreuses années l'opération française
barca notamment présente depuis 2014 est
régulièrement pointée du doigt pour ses
interventions
ces organisations souhaitent que
priorité soit donnée à la protection des
civils
[Musique]
la france qui interrompt donc ses
liaisons aériennes avec le brésil une
décision qui intervient alors que la
situation sanitaire brésilienne inquiète
les autorités notamment à cause du
variant paix à un juge est plus
contagieux et plus létal quentin
mauclair un dernier vol rio paris avant
une date encore indéfinie pour limiter
la propagation du variant brésilien p1
et de ses mutations des liaisons
aériennes entre la france et le brésil
sont désormais suspendus jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
réclamé par l'opposition cette décision
a été annoncée ce mardi après midi par
jean castex lors des questions au
gouvernement à l'assemblée nationale
nous constatons que la situation
s'aggrave et nous avons donc décidé de
suspendre jusqu'à nouvel ordre tous les
vols entre le brésil et la france
ce lundi le gouvernement avait pourtant
écarté la possibilité de stopper des
liaisons aériennes
invité sur lci le ministre délégué aux
transports jean baptiste djebbari
assurait que le bon fonctionnement des
vols étaient imposées par le conseil
d'état une déclaration qui n'a pas
manqué d'être rappelé par certains
membres de l'opposition
je me réjouis de la décision du premier
ministre de suspendre les vols entre la
france et le brésil
il faut maintenant aller plus loin en
suspens dans l'ensemble des vols émanant
de zones à risque notre pays et les
français ne supporteraient pas une
nouvelle vague dévastatrice
poussé dans ses retranchements par mon
collègue patrick ellezelles le premier
ministre annonce à l'instant en réponse
à sa question d'actualité que le
gouvernement suspend les vols en
provenance du brésil
nous avions donc bien raison de le
réclamer il était temps hier le maintien
des lignes aériennes avec le brésil
était imposé par le droit selon le
ministre des transports aujourd'hui
elles sont suspendues ce gouvernement
ment du matin au soir sur ce sujet et
tout le reste
depuis le 3 mars dernier le brésil
recense plus de mille morts par jour
avec un pic à 4239 décès en 24 heures le
8 avril la situation sanitaire ne cesse
de s'empirer dans le plus grand pays
d'amérique latine
la faute aux vaillants p1 et à ces
dizaines de mutation qui rendent la
situation incontrôlable sur le
territoire brésilien
ce mardi les parisiens semblaient plutôt
rassurés par la suspension des vols
entre les deux pays plus la situation
actuelle au brésil qui est assez
catastrophique
la cce il y avait possibilité de par
importer ce virus chez nous ce serait
pas mal
wii fit manque ouest chacun chez soi
pour essayer déjà de d'améliorer cette
pandémie quelle soit pas trop prise
d'assaut voilà je pense qu'il fallait
faire mais c'est trop cher avant je
pense après j'ai passé trop tard mais on
verra après je pense d'ici deux semaines
si on nous ici en tous les cas on
retrouve des variants brésilien bon je
pense que c'est une bonne chose
bah il faut limiter le même
mélange le brassage des populations si
la france interrompt ses vols jusqu'à
nouvel ordre avec le brésil quid des
liaisons avec la guyane dans ce
département d'outre-mer français le
variant brésilien représentait plus de
80% des cas positifs recensés la semaine
dernière pour autant les liaisons
aériennes ne sont pas interrompues pour
le moment
des avions en provenance de cayenne
atterrissent chaque jour à l'aéroport de
paris-orly et pour parler de cette crise
sanitaire nous sommes avec un gilbert
collard député européen rassemblement
national bonsoir gilbert collard merci
d'être avec nous cette décision de
suspendre les vols enfants si j'ose dire
sur la pression politique d'ailleurs
plus que que celle des soignants que
moins de succès sur ce coup là on
imagine que vous saluer cette décision
elle est trop tard selon vous à côté des
tentes
c'est la cacophonie non c'est si c'est
triste c'est désespérant mais ce
gouvernement ne gère que le désordre et
son propre désordre en plus en a le
ministre délégué aux transports monsieur
djebbari qui vient pompeusement comme
s'il était professeur de droit dire dans
un premier temps pour ne pas interrompre
les liaisons aériennes avec le brésil
pour des raisons juridiques ont des
raisons de droit l'imperium du droit à
cinq ans et puis apparemment trop qui
avait l'air de penser ça non c'est le
conseil d'état c'est pas le droit au
conseil d'état c'est une juridiction qui
appliquent le droit administratif
mais on se rend bien compte que ce n'est
pas du tout vrai dans la mesure où
monsieur castex qui ne piétine pas le
droit je sache
sous la pression politique a
décidé que les vols seraient annulés
banc donc on a affaire à une à une
cacophonie on a l'impression qu'ils se
parlent pas entre eux quoi qu'ils
n'arrivent même pas d'une pièce à
l'autre à coordonner leurs points de vue
leurs analyses et franchement ça créé
une panique mentale dans la population
parce qu'on se demande si il y à un
pilote dans dans l'avion et il sait que
pour atterrir il faut sortir le train
d'atterrissage
quand vous pensez que on est on est
enfermé dans des frontières de 10 km et
qu'on met un temps fou pour se rendre
compte qu'il faut fermer les frontières
afin d'empêcher que le virus soit
transporté au monde
remontant quelques quelques mois en
arrière on nous reprocher quand nous
disions qu'il fallait fermer les
frontières extérieures de faire preuve
quelque part de xénophobie virale on
nous disait les virus n'ont pas de
passeport
bon faut maintenant tout le monde sera à
l'évidence que pour éviter parce que
c'est tellement le bon sens qu'ils
commandent qu'on ne comprend pas qu'on
l'ait pas entendu avant tout le monde
s'accorde à dire il faut il faut fermer
les frontières pour éviter la
contamination des zones à risques bon on
est dans une situation de désordre
absolu merco l'accent ferme pas vraiment
les frontières en suspens des vols et
sachant évidemment que ce variant
brésilien il est présent dans 37 pays
dont quasiment toute l'amérique du sud
ça veut dire qu'il faut la sortir de
restrictions beaucoup plus strictes à
l'aéroport ici il faut éviter à partir
du moment un endroit est localisé comme
étant virulent ne porter d'invariants
virulent il faut bien sûr empêcher la
pénétration à l'intérieur du territoire
il faut protéger les les lettres
l'intérieur de la guyane de toute forme
de pénétration
illégale massive venant venant du brésil
également bien sûr il faut protéger nos
populations
mais c'est pas compliqué à comprendre
tout de même oui mais c'est trop tard la
gaine et déjà atteindre parce par ce
variant les écouter ça a été trop tard
tout le temps voilà c'est le
gouvernement du trop tard trop tard pour
les marques quant au début on nous
disait qu'il fallait pas emporté trop
tard pour les lits de réanimation alors
pense était promis d'en créer quinze
mille puis douze mille et qu'on n'a
toujours pas les lits de réanimation
nécessaire trop tard également pour les
vaccins qu'on n'a pas été capable de
produire quand on voit à sanofi qui
s'installe à l'étranger il ya de quoi il
ya de quoi désespérer bon trop tard pour
les tests aussi qui ne sont pas
disponibles partout trop tard pour les
vaccins à propos desquels on ne sait pas
lequel est ben lequel est mauvais
comment il faut le prendre si ces deux
doses trois doses on voit que les
vaccins à pfizer et astrazeneca ont été
approuvés en quelques semaines alors que
pour le vaccin spoutnik il faut près de
douze treize quatorze 14 mois à 12 mois
bon donc on n'arrive pas à comprendre la
manière dont dans ce gouvernement
gouverne c'est un gouvernement un
gouvernant aux enduits clairement au
rassemblement national qu'est ce que
vous demandez il ya encore quelque chose
à demander où ça aussi et c c'est trop
tard écoutez on leur demande d'arrêter
leur d'arrêter leurs conneries je peux
me permettre c'est pas mal hein c'est
pas dans le droit constitutionnel mais
ça dit bien ce que ça veut dire quoi que
une fois pour toute ils cessent de
croire en la communication comme étant
une solution qu'il qui le qu'il prenne
la réalité à bras le corps
regardez le confinement il n'est pas
intervenu pour finalement intervenir
regardez les élections régionales et
départementales ils ont tous
pour les reporter non pas pour des
raisons sanitaires mais parce qu'ils ont
peur d'afficher des cultes et électorale
il crie il serait temps que ce
gouvernement se rende compte que la vie
est tragique
je sais pas gilbert collard va en parler
de ces élections régionales puisque il
ya eu un soutien massif à rester avec
nous de l'assemblée on va le voir sur
ces images pour le maintien de ces
régionales et départementales en france
elles seront seulement décalée d'une
semaine un vote symbolique les députés
avec 443 voix pour 73 contre et 13
abstentions le premier ministre a donc
précisé que des consignes particulières
serait donnée pour les personnes âgées à
mobilité réduite
oui on est co morbidités des bureaux de
vote qui pourront également être placée
en extérieur demain ce sera au tour du
sénat de débattre sur la question
gilbert collard clairement l'exécutif a
dû céder à la pression des autres partis
a concédé qu'elle serait maintenue à ces
élections il à l'exécutif a tenté un
coup notamment en interrogeant les
maires au dernier moment dans des
conditions d'impolitesse qui ont choqué
du reste les élus et en espérant obtenir
de ses élus surpris qu'ils allaient dire
que les élections devaient être reportés
les maires n'ont pas du tout dit cela
ils ont dit que bien au contraire il
fallait maintenir les élections
maintenant posons-nous encore la
question
alors qu'on sait qu'il va y avoir des
élections depuis très très longtemps
ça c'est un fait qui tombe du ciel on
savait pourquoi n'at-on pas déjà mis en
place les mesures d'organisation
pourquoi faut-il tenter un report échoué
dans cette pratique politique pour
décider d'organiser les élections qui ne
sont pas encore organisé alors qu'on est
à deux mois deux mois et demi des
élections
voyez aussi c'est tout ce ce désordre
qui fait qu' on se dit que véritablement
il
coordination il n'y a pas de prise en
compte du réel il n'ya pas
d'anticipation ou et le traitement ou et
le traitement parce qu'enfin on parle
beaucoup des vaccins mais rendez vous
compte que healy à débat sur les vaccins
d'abord sur l'efficacité sur la manière
dont qu'ils doivent être prescrits
appliquée mais il ya aussi des bars sur
l'absence de traitement alors que des
médecins nous disent qu'il ya des
traitements
pourquoi on a abandonné la thérapeutique
pour ne laisser que l'hôpital récupérer
les malades dans des cas très graves qui
vont en réanimation quand il y à delhi
parce qu'il ya pénurie de ligne voilà ce
qui est ce qui est terriblement
angoissant et que ce gouvernement paiera
merci qu'il ne prend pas les choses au
sérieux
merci j'ai percoler député européen et
rennes merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france et en parler en
faute de davantage de rapidité en france
pour recevoir l'injection tiko vie d'un
avocat lyonnais a décidé de faire le
voyage jusqu'en russie pour se faire
vacciner au spoutnik vais le cerveau
russe dans lequel il dit avoir
pleinement confiance mais qui n'est
toujours pas validé par l'agencé
européenne du médicament reportage m
duflot est avocat dans l'agglomération
lyonnaise et sur le sujet de la
vaccination
ilan opinion bien tranchée en france
aujourd'hui nous manquons de vaccins
et d'une part donc tout le monde ne peut
pas être vaccinés comme ils le
souhaitent au moment où il le souhaite
et le plus tôt possible
et puis surtout parce que je n'ai aucune
confiance dans les vaccins qu'on nous
propose que ce soit le vaccin américain
où le vaccin anglo saxons astrazeneca
je n'ai aucune confiance et donc je me
suis tourné tout naturellement vers vers
le vaccin spoutnik v2 russie qui me
semble beaucoup plus sûr est beaucoup
plus sérieux mais voilà le vaccin russe
n'a pas encore été validé par l' agence
européenne du médicament et par
conséquent n'est pas encore disponible
en france
situation qu'il déplore pour l'instant
je regrette que mon pays la france pour
des raisons qui ne sont pas des raisons
médicales et sanitaires refuse l'accès à
ses citoyens aux vaccins spoutnik c'est
pour ça que le vaccin skotnik ne venant
pas à moi eh bien je vais vers le vaccin
ce critique m duflot a donc joint la
parole aux actes et profité d'un
déplacement professionnel à moscou pour
se faire vacciner
à quelques instants de la piqûre tant
attendu pas de signe apparent de stress
non je n'ai pas de pad angoisse
particulière
j'aurais peut-être plus dans le voit si
c'était avec un vaccin le nôtre vaccin
donc je tairai le nom qui est tellement
décriée aujourd'hui en france et
je pense que j'aurais effectivement
beaucoup de l'appréhension et de beurre
pour cet avocat il est cependant
regrettable de devoir venir en russie
pour se faire vacciner alors même qu'en
france nous manquons de vaccins que
d'obliger de de prioriser de choisir les
personnes qui doivent être vaccinés
d'ailleurs ce qui montre que nous avons
passé deux doses de vaccin est alors
qu'il ya du vin vaccins disponibles et
je trouve que c'est un choix
ce que c'est un vrai choix que je
qualifie de criminel
d'autant que la france qui disposait
pourtant d'un véritable savoir-faire n'a
pas encore réussi à développer un vaccin
je suis navré désolé par cette situation
que j'explique par le fait que la france
n'a plus cette aura et n'a plus cette
capacité scientifique de développer les
choses va nous sommes le pays de pasteur
de calmette et guérin de scientifiques
qui ont véritablement bouleversé dans le
bon sens du terme
le panorama paysage sanitaire de nos de
notre du monde entier et aujourd'hui
nous sommes à la traîne
nous sommes le seul pays membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu à ne pas avoir deux vaccins rendez
vous est maintenant pris dans trois
semaines pour la seconde dose de
spoutnik v avant de pouvoir rentrer en
france l'esprit plus léger
notre dame de paris près de deux ans
après son incendie qui a ravagé les
flèches et une partie de sa toiture
toiture l'association défense de
l'environnement robin des bois a déposé
une plainte avec constitution de partie
civile pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui en cause des réseaux
but de plomb dans la zone l'association
estime qu'il faut diligenter une enquête
sur les conséquences sanitaires et
environnementales de l' incendie et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct avec
jacky bonnemains ce directeur de
l'association robin des bois
bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france pourquoi
demander cette heure enquête aujourd'hui
bas parce que il n'y a pas de vaccin
contre le plan et tout incorporation de
plomb est dangereuse pour les organismes
humains et animaux aussi et donc à
partir du moment où il ya eu des
quantités énormes de plomb dans répondu
de pousser à de plomb de répandu dans la
voirie parisienne autour de notre dame
et dans les arrondissements l'ouest de
paris qui ont été survolés par le par le
panache
nous estimons qu'il ya des risques
sanitaires importants et c'est pourquoi
nous nous sommes constitués partie
civile
notre première plainte simple a été
déposée le fin juillet 2019 on a reçu un
courrier du parquet nous disons que l
sauvé est classée sans suite
le 20 décembre 2020 et donc nous ne nous
résignons pas à ce classement sans suite
nous voulons connaître toute la vérité
sur les risques sanitaires
environnementaux les dommages sanitaires
et les dommages environnementaux que
cette catastrophe qui peut être simulé
une catastrophe industrielle a connu
alors à vous écouter à vous entendre on
se demande pourquoi il n'y a pas eu une
enquête avant et que dans une certaine
mesure n'est pas obligatoire il ya eu
une enquête
il y à une enquête ouverte sur les
causes de l'incendié pour essayer de
répartir les responsabilités entre les
différentes parties prenantes négligente
qui n'ont pas renforcé le système d'
alerte samedi alors que notre dame était
en cours de restauration est par contre
le parquet du tribunal judiciaire de
paris estime qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
d'ouvrir dans un premier temps qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire d'ouvrir une
enquête sur les risques sanitaires
donc c'est pourquoi effectivement votre
association avait déjà déposé plainte 1
pour l'âme même motif c'était en août
2019 mais classée sans suite
peut-on davantage y croire cette fois ci
normalement le le pal la doyenne ould
abdou nous le doyen des juges
d'instruction qui sont saisi par une
association de protection de
l'environnement à gré sur l'ensemble du
territoire
normalement il devrait être désigné un
juge d'instruction qui devra mener une
enquête non plus sur les causes de
l'accident et sur les conséquences de
l'accident et nous pensons que toutes
les conséquences ont été minorés
parce que toutes les parties prenantes
qui ont participé par leur négligence à
l' incendie de notre dame sont
exactement les mêmes qui participent à
la reconstruction de notre dame
clairement aujourd'hui vous ressentez
une forme de laxisme ou de déni par
rapport à ce problème de résidus
toxiques n'ont peut-être d'une certaine
incapacité de la magistrature en général
à bien comprendre les enjeux
environnementaux
parce que là c'est une autre dame c'est
une cause majeure mais dans bien
d'autres tribunaux sur des sujets moins
graves ou presque quotidiens comme les
décharges de déchets par exemple la
justice française a une fâcheuse
tendance à classer sans suite
est-ce que vous avez rencontré des
riverains ou des personnes pardonnez moi
qui ont travaillé sur le chantier qui
aurait pu rencontrer des problèmes de
santé
oui on en a on en a
rencontrée mais ça a tellement été un
yo-yo dans les décisions des parties
prenantes la préfecture de police la
mairie de paris le diocèse le ministère
de la culture la préfecture
d'ile-de-france que les informations
étaient difficilement accessibles et que
surtout je ferai un seul exemple pour
les enfants les écoles ont été
décontaminées à partir de l'été en août
septembre dans six écoles la rentrée a
été retardé et il aurait fallu les
fermer tout de suite et les décontaminer
tout de suite c'est ces écoles et autres
autres autre problème il ya cinquante
cinq mille enfants et adolescents les
nourrices dans les crèches les écoles
les lycées ou à paris à paris intra
muros et il aurait fallu faire un
dépistage de plombémie sur ces cinquante
cinq mille enfants quelque chose d'un
protocole relevant d'un protocole
systématique et non pas recommandé aux
parents cinq mois après l'instant dit de
faire des dépistages dans le cadre d'une
démarche volontaire merci beaucoup jacky
bonnemains directeur de l'association
robin des bois d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
la page facebook d'une commune en
moselle censuré par le réseau social en
cause le nom de la ville beach une
insulte en anglais l'algorithme de
facebook et donc automatiquement
supprimé la page 13 mars dernier a été
réactivé que ce matin avec les excuses
du réseau le maire de la commune
regrette cette censure automatique sans
rancune il a invité le patron de
facebook mark zuckerberg à venir visiter
son vidal j'écoutais on n'est pas
déshonoré on passe au dessus les
bitchoise et les beats prennent de la
hauteur ce sont des gens valeur et de
qualité ça pousse à réfléchir certains
s'autocensurent forcément quand vous
quand vous préparez les choses et quand
vous décidez de donner des informations
mais ça pousse surtout à la réflexion à
se dire oui peut-être vous est peut-être
raison de se dire est ce qu'on va
communiquer par rater le vecteur on va
le faire autrement
la problématique est l'enfant aussi
c'est effectivement de savoir quelle est
la mesure dans quelle mesure vous pouvez
vous agir face à une telle censure si on
utilise ce mot là qu'elle est pouvoir
vous avez entre personnes physiques ont
tenté institutions vis-à-vis des gaffes
1 moi j'attends déjà facebook aussi
communique sur notre propre page et nous
apporte un élément un élément de réponse
à des demandes excuse un événement de
considérations j'ai accepté les excuses
qui ont été présentés ce matin mais je
vous le dis on pardonne mais on ne peut
pas oublier parce qu'elle est certain
que ça puisse éventuellement se
reproduire en l'occurrence considère que
facebook est assez intelligent pour
faire attention maintenant pour ce qui
nous concerne ça peut arriver à d'autres
il faut un nez au moins être méfiant
donc dans le reste de l'actualité
alexandre benalla renvoyé en
correctionnelle l'ex-collaborateur d'
emmanuel macron à l'elysée affrontera un
second procès pour des coups portés des
manifestants à paris le 1er mai 2018 est
détaillé avec notre reporter katia
technique
les soucis judiciaires se poursuivent
pour alexandre benallal ancien chargé de
mission d' emmanuel macron à l'elysée le
juge d'instruction chargé de l'enquêté
sur les violences du 1er mai 2000
18la renvoyé devant le tribunal
correctionnel et ce pour violences
volontaires immixtions sans titre dans
l'exercice d'une fonction publique port
d'armé port public d'un signe non
autorisées sont renvoyés également
devant le tribunal vincent kraz anciens
salariés la république en marche et deux
représentants des forces de police alors
les soucis d'alexandre benalla avaient
commencé alors qu'une vidéo avait été
publiée on le voyait portant un casque
est frappant un manifestant place de la
contrescarpe à paris en marge du défilé
du 1er mai une enquête préliminaire pour
violence volontaire avait été ouverte
et puis en août 2010 8 une seconde vidéo
avait surgi on y voyait toujours
alexandre bédat la frappant d'autres
manifestants cette fois ci au jardin des
plantes à paris mais toujours le 1er mai
et outre les violences ils portaient un
brassard de la police nationale elle en
avait bien évidemment pas le droit
alors de tels agissements avaient
déclenché une vive polémique un séisme
politique
et puis il faut ajouter qu alexandre
benalla a déjà été renvoyé en
correctionnelle a cette fois ci pour
l'utilisation frauduleuse de passeports
diplomatiques lors d'un voyage en
afrique et ce alors qu'il avait cessé
toute collaboration avec l'elysée
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
nous partirons aux états unis mais n'a
pauliste qui reste sous tension la mort
dimanche d'un jeune homme noir abattu
par la police lors d'un contrôle routier
suscite l'indignation plein procès sur
le meurtre de joe joe floyd et puis à
nous parlerons du ca est né cet appel
d'une cinquantaine de ng pour un
changement de stratégie et corps dans la
priorité à la protection des civils
non pas selon à l'action militaire
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de nero et gagarine
était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'on nous trouve la
peuplent c'était une volonté collectés
vous le savez comme moi qui dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort
du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
ce sont les trafiquants de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage
montagnes de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose de
l'argent sale devient très rapidement et
très facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dire nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards qui sut du trafic de
stupéfiants ont été absorbés par un
certain nombre de banques aux états unis
qui d'ailleurs ont été poursuivis en
justice et ont payé des amendes en
conséquence
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france qui
vous nous rejoignez minneapolis où
tensions au lendemain d'une deuxième
nuit consécutive de manifestations et de
violences
des centaines de personnes mobilisées
après la mort d'un jeune noir américain
il a été tué par la police lors d'un
contrôle routier valentin carpentier la
colère n'est pas retombée à minneapolis
après la mort du chanteur ait un jeune
afro-américain battu ce dimanche par la
police lors d'un contrôle la ville a
connu une deuxième soirée de rentrer
population et forces de l'ordre
un nouveau drame qui passe mal auprès
des habitants nous ne faisons que
manifester pacifiquement nous n'allons
pas continuer à supporter que la police
tue des personnes noires sans raison
pendant des contrôles routiers ou parce
qu'elles ont des problèmes de santé
mentale
c'est juste une façon que nous avons
apprises de manifester ensemble notre
solidarité cela continue à se produire
il est accablant de devoir se réveiller
de voir qu'un jeune homme noir a été
assassiné par les forces de l'ordre
j'ai 25 ans cet homme avait 20 ans dont
terry wright avait 20 ans il aurait pu
être mon petit frère pour éviter tout
débordement supplémentaires minneapolis
a instauré un couvre-feu dès 19h mais
des dizaines de manifestants étaient
toujours présents lundi soir face au
commissariat de bookeen center la ville
voisine où a eu lieu l'événement
tragique
les forces de l'ordre ont de leur côté
communiquer par le biais du chef de la
police locale
jugeant cette mort accidentelle selon ce
dernier la jante responsable de la mort
de dompter wright aurait confondu son
arme à feu avec son taser
son nom n'a pas été rendu public
contrairement à l'enregistrement vidéo
du drame une affaire qui a poussé joe
biden à prendre la parole
je n'ai pas appelé la famille de john
terry wright mais mes prières se tourner
vers eux ce qu'il s'est passé vraiment
tragique mais je pense qu'il faut
attendre de voir ce que nous dira
l'enquète l'intégralité de l'enquêté
nous savons que la colère la douleur la
souffrance qui existe chez les personnes
noires dans ce contexte est réelle
sérieuse et importante mais cela ne
justifie pas la violence ni les pillages
à la suite de ce drame
le sport a également été mise à l'arrêt
dans la ville la nba la ligue majeure de
baseball et la ligue nationale de hockey
ont décidé de reporter les rencontres
prévues tout en présentant leurs
condoléances
enfin la mère de dompter wright a pris
la parole pour demander un retour au
calme
reste à savoir si elle sera entendue
les nouvelles exactions policières qui
intervient en plein procès du meurtre de
giorgio floyd
hier la journée a été marquée par le
témoignage d'un frère de la victime qui
a brossé et lui le portrait d'un homme
qu'il a qualifié de fils à maman comme
d'autres experts avant lui un
cardiologue un changeur fleury était
bien mort par asphyxie mais non d'une
overdose après avoir examiné tous les
faits et preuves de cette affaire je
peux affirmer avec un haut degré de
certitude médicale que georges klein
n'est pas mort d'une simple crise
cardiaque et qu'il n'est pas mort d'une
overdose hérité de nadaï from our love
in space dans cette affaire monsieur
georges floyd est mort d'un arrêt cardio
respiratoire qui a été causé par un
faible taux d'oxygène et ses faibles
niveaux d'oxygène on est tendu par une
contention et l'asphyxié positionnelle
auquel il a été soumis et les échéances
successives
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis new york avec chadwick mohand
journaliste politique c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir chaque brique mot merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france havre
en plein procès derek chauvine on vient
de le voir on imagine que ce qui s'est
passé à minneapolis a accentué les
tensions les maths raciale à son si
prévisible qu'on peut pas les régler
sans ambages dessus c'est au début du
printemps que cela a commencé et il ya
des pillages dans les grandes
je ne sais pas si c'est un peu accentué
la tension qui était déjà très élevé ce
démocrate me rapporter le congrès et la
maison blanche
et pourtant même les populations n'est
toujours pas satisfaite
il ya mis du temps mais vers leurs
propres conclusions sont descendus dans
la rue avant de connaître les détails de
l'anc est effectivement l'enregistrement
vidéo
l'incident a été publié en même temps
les médias la presse jeu toujours que ce
jeu ils étaient très organisés ils
étaient prêts à descendre dans la rue
il avait déjà imprimé tout leur affiche
un encart que je ne sais pas qui a payé
pour cela comment j'ai fait aussi
rapidement sans doute s'attendre à
d'autres événements du genre pendant
l'été ce qui va arriver après le verdict
le verdict du procès chauvine je pense
que dans tous les cas il y aura des
émeutes
alors c'est vrai qu'on vient d'entendre
un criminologue qui voit là affirmé
qu'il était bien mort du jeu feuilles
par asphyxie et et non pas par une
overdose là à minneapolis est un petit
peu différent si une policière qui s'est
trompé d'armes qui a utilisé une arme au
lieu de son teaser est ce que c'est
comparable justement en termes de
résonance auprès de l'opinion publique
deux publics et les élus tiennent les
médias s'en fiche
tout ce qui les intéresse c'est anwar al
un fichier de police
on a commencé à parler de racisme de
violences avant même de savoir lequel
les officiers abêtir et maintenant ils
nous savons que c'est une femme on ne
sait pas quelle est la couleur de peau
de cette policière
le 6 janvier une femme blanche a été tué
par un officier lors d'une émeute devant
une capitale officiers sont une identité
n'a pas du tout plu et il n'y a pas eu
d'émeutes dans la rue bien sûr parce que
considéré que cette personne était une
conservatrice forcément couleur blanche
on s'est fait chier a contacté procès
qu'on coûte un jeu flash doit être
encore voir les autres témoins elles
étaient joints de la défense qui vont
dire qu'il n'a pas été asphyxiées qu'il
s'agissait en fait d'une gouvernance
donc on n'a pas encore eu les deux côtés
sont ils moins sûr à l'eau au cours du
réquisitoire on dit qu'il a été tué mais
je ne pense pas que les procureurs
sentir si bien que cela tant se penser
l'homme était n'en parle pas beaucoup et
donc cela veut dire que ça ne marche pas
très bien pour manger un disque de
réquisitoire n'était pas très bon et
maintenant c'est au tour de la défense
mais cela n'a aucune importance les gens
n'entendent que ces quelques mots
officiers tu ailles voir et développent
leur rhétorique ou taux de cela c'est
vrai souvent tué par des policiers
mais ce qui est important diffusez cette
rhétorique selon laquelle les âmes
noires sont
d'autres maisons d'accueil les un mois
ne passe pas les mêmes chances que les
autres ils sont pourchassés gens les
officiels de bons situation que rien ne
peut changer cela ils sont victimes
exact de l'incident les médias la presse
les militants adorent leur discours très
calibrée et c'est l'histoire qui veulent
diffuser le pays et auprès de la
communauté noire premier temps ces
personnes qui résistaient l'arrestation
personne ne veut qu'il meure
oui il serait encore vivant s'il n'avait
pas résisté
alors c'est très politique évidemment
c'est s'est fait aux etats unis puisque
à une grosse division avant les
élections par les dunes et mériterait
fracturée c'était important la réaction
de joe biden joe biden qui dit
comprendre la colère mais qui la jugent
qu'ils jugent inacceptables les
violences et les pillages que pensez
vous de cette réaction du président
américain souhaite offenser les émeutes
sur les pierres kamala harris a fait la
promotion d'un fin pour payer les frais
de loc de justice de ceux utilisés les
bons mots veut condamner à ces actes
sans aller trop loin et il n'y aura pas
de poursuites contre ses métiers ses
pierres continuent à effectuer cette
rhétorique déjà développé le 6 janvier
après
la tête du capitaine pour lui il s'agit
de démontrer qu'il est bi partisan parce
qu'il choisit mais le parti d'évoquer
lorsque ils ont une certaine agitation
politique et pas l'autre partie la plus
à gauche du congrès après cet incident a
dit que nous devrions nous débarrasser
complètement de la prison et de la
police et c'est effectivement ce que
vise à lille party l'ailé comme à gauche
les plus gauchiste des démocrates mais
et des bas et elle ne va pas être aussi
explicite je baille de moossou est pas
mécontenter sa base électorale en tant
que président c'est un homme âgé blanc
ces gens qui sont dans la rue johnny
volontiers qu'il n'aimait pas joe biden
et n'ont pas voté pour lui aujourd'hui
je vous parlais de cette division avant
les élections est ce qu'elle est
toujours aussi palpable cette amérique
fracturé où les choses se sont apaisées
depuis l'élection de joe biden je ne
pense pas que la situation s'est apaisée
je pense que la gauche les démocrates
sont les pires gagnant que j'ai vu de ma
vie
ils sont toujours en colère contre
quelque chose ils le sont toujours à
l'achat ce soutien de donald trump
en tout cas jusqu'à cet incident
maintenant on est de retour en 2020 il
ya ces ailettes et
et ces manifestations l'autre côté du
spectre aux politiques les soutiens de
donald trump je le vois sur les résaux
sociaux eux se sont calmés ils ont
accepté le résultat depuis que donald
trump s'est fait expulser de ces réseaux
sociaux beaucoup ont décidé de les
quitter également donc la température a
beaucoup baissé à droite on concèdera
cette sorte de cycle infernal de
l'indignation l'indignation et il
pleurait de satisfaction je sais ce
qu'ils aient obtenu une forme de
transformation radicale de la société
ils veulent reconstruire les états unis
en le sort de l'utopie marxiste est
celle qu'ils ont connue pour la première
fois à l'université ils seront donc
jamais satisfait les démocrates comme je
l'aï dit on espère tout simplement ne
pas les énerver et réussira à maintenir
une apparence tout et et d'autre wen et
aucun démocrate n'est véritablement
mécontent de voir un homme noir se faire
tuer par la police car cela unifient
leurs bases électorales
merci shadwick amour journaliste
politique pro républicain merci d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
les tensions entre l'iran et les
occidentaux ne faiblissent pas
l'annnonce de téhéran d'enrichir son
uranium à 60% fermement été condamnée
par la france aujourd'hui pour sa part
joe biden y voient une provocation le
président américain a dit toutefois prêt
à continuer les négociations sur le
nucléaire iranien des discussions qui
ont été repoussées à ce jeudi au vu des
tensions actuelles le nucléaire iranien
également au coeur des discussions entre
téhéran et moscou aujourd'hui le
ministre des affaires étrangères russe
sergueï lavrov et rend lui dans le golfe
persique pour afficher le soutien de la
russie à son partenaire iranien
les précisions avec thé au combat
[Applaudissements]
faire front commun c'est semble-t-il
l'objectif poursuivi par sergueï lavrov
et mohammad javad zarif respectivement
ministre des affaires étrangères de la
russie et de l'iran
les deux hommes ont affiché leur
proximité ce mardi à téhéran en pleine
négociation pour relancer l'accord de
vienne sur le nucléaire iranien alors
que les sujets de tension se multiplient
avec les occidentaux
dernier épisode en date les sanctions
adoptée par bruxelles à l'encontre de
huit responsables iraniens pour leur
rôle présumé dans la répression de
manifestations en 2019 une erreur selon
sergueï lavrov bien une vidéo pas que je
n'ai pas encore vu le texte complet de
cette décision de l'union européenne
mais le fait lui-même soulève un très
grand nombre de questions dans l'union
européenne il n'y a aucune coordination
la main droite ne sais pas ce que fait
la gauche c'est malheureux mais si cette
décision a été prise de manière
volontaire en pleines négociations à
vienne pour sauver l'accord sur le
nucléaire lors ce n'est plus malheureuse
c'est une erreur à chacun de leur côté
les dirigeants iraniens ont annoncé
suspendre tout dialogue sur les droits
humains avec les vingt-sept par ailleurs
téhéran accuse washington d'avoir
participé à une opération menée par
israël dimanche un site d'enrichissement
d'uranium situé dans le centre du pays a
été la cible d'un acte de sabotage
selon les autorités iraniennes une
attitude inacceptable selon le ministre
des affaires étrangères iranien
en réaction à cette attaque l'iran a
annoncé son intention d'enrichir son
uranium à hauteur de 60% par rich
qu'alibaba ce cachet nous n'avons aucun
problème à revenir à nos engagements
mais les américains doivent savoir que
jamais des sanctions
cani des actes de sabotage il
procureront un instrument de négociation
que ces actions ne feront que compliquer
encore la situation à gauche radicale
l'iran et la russie ont néanmoins
affirmé leur volonté commune de
sauvegarder l'accord de vienne un accord
qui ne tient plus qu'à un fil
américains et iraniens exige
mutuellement que l'autre partie fasse le
premier pas avant de revenir aux
engagements initiaux
une situation qui semble inextricable et
que les négociateurs réunis actuellement
dans la capitale autrichienne auront
bien du mal à résoudre en algérie
plusieurs centaines d'étudiants ont
manifesté comme chaque mardi à
l'occasion du irak ce mouvement de
contestation qui touche le pays depuis
plus de deux ans et une protestation qui
s'est déroulé au premier jour du ramadan
à alger quelques échauffourées ont eu
lieu entre les forces de l'ordre et
certains étudiants et contestataires
réclament un changement du système
politique actuel ans quittait libération
de militants du miracle arrêtés
récemment
je suis venu ici aujourd'hui pour le
bien de l'état de vérité de justice et
de droits pour la libération de nos
frères incarcérés samedi dernier est
également avant parce que nos frères
souffrent en prison nous exigeons leur
libération il a mis en place d'un état
de justice de vérité de loi joyeux
ramadan à tous les prisonniers d'opinion
nous en sommes au 112e mardi de
manifestations dues
mouvement étudiant qui fait partie
intégrante du mouvement du peuple
algérien le mouvement est inébranlable
dans ses objectif qui est d'offrir un
état de justice et de la loi
le contre est en l'état d'institutions
la liberté de la presse et la liberté de
la justice
nous sommes dans la rue aujourd'hui et
manifestons entre la fermeté de nos
revendications et demain objectif le
mouvement populaire restera même si vous
arrêtez les personnes premier rang dans
les manifestations on sait que si les
premiers rangs sont arrêtés les 2e 3e et
4e faibliront au contraire cela ne fera
qu'augmenter notre ténacité et notre
force cinquantaine d'objets pour un
changement de stratégie au sel cette
région et ses habitants subissent les
affrontements entre groupes terroristes
j'ai dit ces forces de sécurité depuis
de nombreuses années déjà
l'opération française barca notamment
présente depuis 2014 est régulièrement
pointée du doigt pour ses interventions
ces organisations souhaitent que
priorité soit donnée à la protection des
civils les explications la coalition
citoyenne pour le sahel créé en 2020 par
diverses organisations africaines
appelle un réagencement drastique des
priorités dans la région comme le font
de nombreux acteurs sur le terrain
depuis plusieurs années cette alliance
déplore la réponse exclusivement
sécuritaire des forces militaires
présentes au sahel au détriment de la
protection des civils
depuis le déclenchement du conflit au
mali en 2012
la zone dite des 'trois frontière entre
le niger le burkina faso et le mali subi
les attaques des groupes djihadistes
affiliés à al qaïda au groupe etat
islamique dans un rapport publié ce
mardi la coalition citoyenne pour le
sahel indique que davantage de civils
ont été tués par des soldats censés les
protéger que par des groupes armés non
étatiques
en 2020 le nombre de civils tués par des
militaires est sans précédent
les opérations des militaires français
de la force barkan et des armées de la
région sont régulièrement pointés du
doigt le 1er avril dernier cette ong ont
signé un appel à faire la lumière sur
une frappe aérienne de la force barkan
menées le 3 janvier 2020 au mali dans la
région de douane ça d'après l'onu cinq
membres présumés d'un groupe armé était
visé la frappe aurait finalement causé
la mort de trois d'entre eux est celle
de 19 civils présents au même mariage
le rapport de la coalition citoyenne
pour le sahel prônant dialogue avec
l'ensemble des parties au conflit y
compris les djihadistes
elle souhaite également résoudre la
crise de gouvernance au sein des états
dans une région où près de la moitié de
la population vite avec moi de dollars
25 par jour selon les critères
internationaux
pour en parler nous sommes avec ali tout
le quart à directeur du centre des
études sécuritaires et stratégiques au
sel bonsoir ali
tounkara merci d'être avec nous la
coalition citoyenne pour le sel qui a
émis un certain nombre de
recommandations axées sur les besoins
des populations il est encore le temps
de changer de stratégie
l' avantage pour ces données sont non
gouvernementales elles sont au contact
régulier par maman sont en contact
permanent avec les populations
donc les attentes et celles ci sont
clairement entendit passeuse on dit j'ai
dansé fait effectivement le sprint aux
jo les maliens fois aux attaques
touristes les nigériens le burkinabè on
pourra vous attaquez vous pourrez
découvrir
naturellement ces populations vous du
look effectivement les réponses
méditation circuit nécessaires mais
elles permettent pas à elles seules de
continuer tout une paix durable d'où
effectivement à cette nécessité et de
refonte des listes réponse militaire
aujourd'hui qui sont proposés par les
seigneurs et par les partenaires à nos
clients de la sauce marque en france
elle alors comment se fait-il selon vous
que que malgré la présence accrue des
militaires de l'opération barkan les
menaces contre les civils mais n'est
finalement jamais cessé d'augmenter
alors ils ne sont quand même plus ses
forces partenaires et les forces
nationales allant plus une fonction
vitale là dans cette ligue contre le
gouffre et les coups violents
même si le coma doit s'inscrit dans la
bulle et en dépit de cette présence
combinée des forces nationales et
internationales les populations
effectivement ont le sentiment d'être le
plus en plus éloigné de cette poupée à
rechercher par sa population et donc
vous dire qu'effectivement l'édifiante
et le poste du centre vuli proposent ils
elle met le focus est de mettre l'accent
sur le team militaire or la sécurité
dans ces différents endroits aux dix
questions d'organisation sociale que
sont la gouvernance si vous regardez
aujourd'hui les 4 500 l certes on a une
expérience mais lesquels action logement
est gommée par l'ex défense sécurité
dans l'écrasante majorité des réponses
proposées par l'organe de 500 sont des
réponses malheureusement militaire or
les problèmes
il est soulevé le problème il est
culturel le problème est le même entre
produit donc de ce fait les populations
et les ordinations de supprimer 6000
vers davantage que l'élite militaire
syrienne que les huit militaires
occidentales notamment françaises écoute
des prises en plissés cri de coeur les
populations sont elles aujourd'hui que
les associe pleinement effectivement
dans l'élaboration des fondatrices
hâtive concernant jusqu'ici
malheureusement si vous le gagnez du
sommet de cours ou rétention mais n'a
aucune et ce sommet n'a associé tv
actuelles qui sont les populations de
ces endroits pour attaque terroriste
la coalition citoyenne préconise le
dialogue avec les djihadistes
est ce que c'est possible pour vous au
delà de la possibilité cette année
système souris vous ne pouvez pas
combattre avec efficacité pertinence des
actes ex bâti on une référence
idéologique des actes qui se battent ou
nommé référent religieux pas des simples
un poste canaux adhérer sans réponse
militaire
de ce fait il est extrêmement important
jour dit que c'est trop friand look six
ans elle est à peu près les coups
violents et derrière laquelle offre
elle est également il faut le rappeler
proposé par les maliens lors de la
conférence nationale
en 2010 cette dénomination inclusif à
fin 2010 9 9 également récemment burkina
je viens de quitter le boucler à peine
trois jours où les populations dans les
cas la majorité sur terre et s'il ya ne
soit déclenchée si vous perdez coups
violents
les réponses militaires ou des
reconnaissances elles sont nécessaires
elles ne peuvent aucunement combattre
cette idéologie terroristes mais
l'impossibilité à elle seule ne peut pas
permettre de comprendre davantage tous
et bienvenue compliqué liés à la gestion
du fonds s'est confié à la firme sociale
laquelle possède malheureusement amis
certaines catégories de population si la
touche pas chez elles sont excités de sa
catégorie des tricycles ou descendante
investir donc comment allez vous arrivez
à des réponses durables dans un conflit
qui autant ultime est pas de détention
kong qui ont pour le moment les français
à des tensions que l'on peut m'en excuse
emmené à géométrie variable sans
pourtant associé effectivement
pleinement
c'est une population aujourd'hui qui
vivent dans le module merci à lee
tounkara d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur du
centre des études sécuritaires et
stratégiques au sel et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain pour le contrer sur l'actualité
dans quelques minutes avec emilie google
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain à 20 heures
beaucoup
[Musique]
la sphère art chagos comment ce family
office at il réussi à provoquer un
nouveau vent de panique sur les marchés
mais aussi des pertes massives pour
plusieurs l établissement bancaire
utilisé l'effet de levier pour gagner de
l'argent en bourse ça se fait tous les
jours
en fait c'est toute cette incitation à
toujours pouvoir gagner plus avec
l'argent gratuit de la fed